>> Pete:GOING TO SEE.
STARS IN THE NBA.
>> Stan: THERE'S NO QUESTION --R
COURT.
IT WAS LIKE A BLUR.
I'M NOT EXAGAG SOON.
>> Brian: BRAND JA MORANT
REBOUND, MORANT.
>> Brevin: WE HAVE TO SEE THIS
ONE.
HERE IS
YOU SEE THE THREE-POINT
SHOOTING STORY NOT VEVE
LOOK AT THIS, IT'S AMAZING.
WITH THE LEFT HAND AGAIN, GOT T
PETEFINISH
FOR MORANT TO HANG IN THE AIR
>> MORANT, THREE SECONDS.
HE MAKES IT LOOK SO
25-16 LARGEST LEAD FOR PHOENIX
THE LEAD. THERE IS ONE FOR R  L
LAURENT, FIRST TO STAY IN, DOWN.
>>THE BALL IS
PICKED UP BY
MINNESOTA DOES NOT HAVE A FOUL
TO GIVE.
GRIZZLIES.
3 POINT SHOOTING HAS BEEN A
STRENGTH FOR ?
WESTBROOK AND LeBRON JAMES WERE
FIND AND
WATCH OVER AND OVER AND MOVE WI
BASKETBALL.
>> HE CHECKS IN.
LOOK AT THIS PASS. GETS
IT IN AND ANOTHER PAIN SCORE.
THEY LIVED AT 55-54.
UNDERNEATH
THE OTHER SIDE.
STILL ABLE TO FINISH PULLING TH
SHOOTING THREES
BEHIND HIM, THROWS IT DOWN.WAS
THREE. AGAINST
McDANIELS.
>> Brevin: IT WILL BE A BROKEN
RECORD BY THE END OF THE BAC, A
FOUL BEFORE THE SHOT BY DESMOND
BANE.
IT WILL BE THE SECOND ON
DESMOND BANE.
>> Brevin: TONIGHT.
WITH ALL THE INJURIES, HE GOT
REALBODY GETS BACK FOR THE
THUNDER.
THAT
THERE IS MORANT WITH AN EASY
>> Pete: REGRESSION TO THE MEAN
CAN
>> Pete: THE ROOKIE OUT OF USC,
HERE'S MORANT GOING STRONG TO M
BEHIND THE BACK.
AND SCORES.
THE MIAMI TEAM LOCKING DOWN,
>>